all right Mike you're on the air I'm
very proud of you for following through
with the contest yesterday it was really
really great yes the diaper contest
Richard was such a shoe and I thought
because he's so used to peeing in his
diaper he drinks so much water but when
he should his pants which by the way I
don't think was an accident I have some
bad news oh I don't want to get in
trouble
what'd you do I could smell it that [ __ ]
had an axe
disqualify you [ __ ] you diaper
Richard do me a favor I want there'll be
no repercussions I want to know please I
promise you you are safe you do I'm
granting you immunity like the Muller
investigations I in all my years I was
FARC man okay I mean I have farted on
the air a million times and and then
some and whenever I fart I know if I'm
gonna [ __ ] and I certainly know when
[ __ ] comes out I really do believe for
comedy purposes yesterday you kind of
[ __ ] you let it happen I would I swear
I'm looking you right in the eyes I
would tell you the truth if I meant to
do that
I did not mean to [ __ ] on the air it's a
soft turd but you're saying the [ __ ] was
an accident and you had no idea I swear
no idea Wow how is that possible I mean
I [ __ ] before I came to work right now
check your pants you knew when you [ __ ]
your pants yeah yeah without it down
even if you [ __ ] your pants and you
didn't know it I'll give you that you're
saying like it was a little juicy in
your diaper you get up to walk you take
two steps you don't feel that you're
NASA's like got a liquid in it there was
two rounds of pee in that diaper but
your ass crack right the peepee isn't in
your aspect you can tell when you walk I
couldn't it was so sloshy in there
I just gross I've never been at the
urinal I didn't accidentally [ __ ] down
my legs right you know do you know when
you fart you kind of know instinctively
how much how hard to push
I was thinking cuz you asked me about it
why is my [ __ ] so loose yeah and this
is
I have some theories and I was because I
don't I've never taken it except for a
finger for a prostate check [ __ ]
theory I think it the way I wipe I am I
try to get so clean I put shove the
paper up in my I do the whole and even
my finger and hyper try to clean you
poke around a [ __ ] all the men's yeah
you must be fisting yourself to make
that loose I mean that would make you
five fingers